I'm here to tell you tonight that our
new majority will prepared to do things
differently it starts with cutting
spending instead of increasing it this
time it's going to be different seems
like we've heard that before it's going
to be different the GOP stampeded to
victory in the 1994 midterm elections
thanks in large part to a big crop of
freshmen this is truly a wildly historic
night they vowed to cut spending no
wasteful program was safe small programs
like the federal helium fund were to be
abolished same for Biggie's like the
departments of commerce and education
the GOP targeted more than 200 programs
for complete and utter elimination so
what happened did they abolish that
Commerce Department so plump with
corporate welfare nope didn't shrink it
either in fact today it's bigger than
ever ditto for the Education Department
in 10 years after the Republican
revolution the 101 largest program
slated for elimination actually grew by
combined twenty-seven percent the class
of 94 did manage to abolish the helium
fund but total spending kept going up
and from mark Foley's page problem to
all the other sexcapades the GOP class
of 94 has proven they're just not into
restraint be it sexual or fiscal let's
start right now by recognizing that this
is not a time for celebration that's for
sure in fact the countdown to
disappointment starts now